welcome to the bro army
welcome to the fundraising charity for
cried welcome welcome welcome everybody
is anyone here is always so awkward
starting to remember why I don't do live
I don't see anyone
cool well I guess it's just me and
whoever is watching this afterwards for
whatever reason your dingus I figured
people would be waiting though oh god
I'm at this lonely maybe I'm not even
lying cool wallet it's been good this
has been great so far do I have a chat
and said too late
something I'm actually just alone here
all right this should be a good time oh
there it is okay 22000 watching oh where
is everyone
it's pretty low pretty low why do I not
see the comments chat is disabled why is
chat disabled ah let me just oh there it
is an able chat sorry
x-play no one commenting that's great
welcome everybody today we're gonna
raise money for crying an amazing
charity that changes kids life in India
we're helping 9 year olds s 9 year olds
we already done an amazing job
eighty-five thousand has been donated so
far I'm seriously blown away that's more
than half already
let's help nine year old Bruce
I can finally use my perk emotes that's
right I'm by streaming again for the
first time in just a while just a small
while that I crashed the site which site
which one of them it was so confusing
yesterday because we launched the
campaign and I had donated to it but
then the website crash so I just created
a new one but if you donated to that one
it will all count towards this campaign
anyway so don't worry I will add up
everything and this money goes directly
to cry I I'm in touch with them as well
so don't have to worry about that
Congrats 474 million thank you very much
I remember when we hit 67 million and I
was like well this is it oh wait no I
thought I turned off super chat what the
[ __ ] YouTube YouTube takes a cut of
super chat that's why I want to turn it
on
goddamnit
[Music]
all right if you donate it so far
I'll count it up at afterwards thanks
for the great comments by the way I see
you guys amazing
can't beat it but okay um turn off super
chat stop oh that's so sweet there's so
many Indian currencies thank you guys
I love my Indian brooch from Bombay to
Bangladesh okay it should be off now
[Music]
the guys recognize the background music
very nice please avoid bridges during
this live stream I'll make no promises
[Music]
is it off turn off I've already turned
you off super chat chit chat is like a
set a disease
please stay ring me please stop there we
go okay
let me just go through them anyway I'll
just donate these directly it's a shame
they they haven't implemented their new
feature in Europe where it goes directly
to charities
[Music]
so if you want to donate link is in the
description we're here to raise money
for crying it's right there underneath
me maybe I should have put on the screen
but I feel like if you are able to go
through with in transaction you're able
to also find hey see where the
description is just what I think I
should have streamed on Twitch while
there's more people watching and YouTube
so I don't think so buddy
guess again even though we didn't gasps
don't insult India that's right
we're not here to insult India we're
here to help you what do you do when
you're broke I don't know you get a job
oh great from Spalding to India clap
clap
thank your lambda even though I'm not
supposed to get any more super chat
they're still going in somehow
I don't know why
[Music]
have you seen John trans new video yes I
have it's absolutely amazing he honestly
if this was some charity I would say go
and watch that in his name I mean it's
like every fourth comments is something
about a bridge hey we'd love India we
just don't like t-series you got damn
right I don't like you t-series maybe
just not very much
let me just close my door
[Music]
[Music]
I was feeding Edgar
yep there's my favorite tune from that's
our own yet
we already owned up to thousand from
85,000 thank you very much for all the
donations super cool why the headphones
because I like music is that so crazy
[Music]
let us see Edgar hey there's the grand
finale you have to hit the sub sub ball
this is not why we're here no ma'am
we're about subbing when we hit the goal
of 150,000 thanks when I was show head
girl
how much is it nice
[Music]
I realize how absolutely terrible I am
at this there's just a couple things I
want to get into just waiting for people
to pop in
[Music]
[Music]
why's Poots streaming soon to raise
money for charity that's right let's
keep this Brenda why you don't like
t-series well funny you ask we actually
worked on a video me Joel and Dave and
[Music]
it's coming out soon soon ish and I
don't want to give anything away but it
it will talk about just then it's pretty
good I'm excited for it we we did this
shot where we filled the whole room up
with balloons I don't know for some
reason I thought that would be really
cool to fill the whole room up with
balloons and then my hand this is
completely ruined from blowing up
balloons looks like I'm turning into
zombie or something okay I think we have
enough people in here
[Music]
so for those of you don't know we're
raising funds for crying it's an amazing
charity that helps children in India and
prevent them from a couple issues one of
the main ones is child labor as I
mentioned in my video if you haven't
seen it already it's the latest video up
on my channel ten point three million
kids in India are under child labor
between the age of 5 and 14 and 23
million so even more than double are
between the age of 15 and 18 so that
means that one in 11 kids in India are
working so this is a big problem and
cries an amazing charity that works to
prevent that and they recognize that
it's not so easy to just rescue kids
because there's deeper issues with it
that there's high demand for cheap labor
and and kids want to need to help out
their families as well so they've cry
the charity that we're raising funds for
down in our description highly encourage
you to donate they focus on the root
issue of these problems by interacting
with parents community leaders and
discussing these damaging effect to
actually create an impact they wrote to
me as well and reached out and they gave
me a couple of stories about some things
that they've changed which was really
amazing to hear about and I wanted to
this music is a little distracting you
donate by the link in the description
you know what
can I just add like a text to this
really quick so people know because I
see so many people ask how do i donate I
thought it would be obvious oh [ __ ] does
it say donate my stream I deleted that
are you kidding me
oh my god alright I'll adjust it later
yeah Oh God have I been getting
donations through the stream lamps hey
Justin everything it let a bit got
messed up I'm so bad at live streaming
you can tell now can't you Jesus Christ
it's still there now YouTube chucked me
okay yeah yeah there's $100 that's all
right
thank God thing is if I if I do it
through streamlines apparently there's
like a big problem it's better if the
money goes directly to I thought it
would just get more donations but it
just makes it more complicated okay um
here's how you donate guys you go to
GoFundMe calm the link is in the
description I'm also gonna add it now on
the screen in case for some reason
whatever reason you can't see it
there we go I managed to do a text guys
thank you so much for all the donations
so far I'm sick ninety-two Jesus Christ
that's amazing I'm so proud of you guys
I'm so glad this we're finally doing
first of all finally doing a charity
class again and the fact that you guys
really show that this is a fan base or
group of people that actually is
positive I feel like my audience gets a
really bad read which is really not
justify this is so cool to see all the
donations so far
sorry about the mishaps so like I
mentioned before Christ sent me a letter
that I wanted to read out because I
thought it was really inspiring and a
great story so this first one is from
the first story this they sent me three
stories and I'll read them out but I
just thought they were so great so the
first one is for from this kid whose
name is Naveen and this is what they
wrote me Naveen is this amazing kid at
one of our cry projects he started
working at eleven because his family
needed his income he also dropped out of
school because you know that's what
always happened kids cannot manage
school and work so Naveen worked at a
roadside tea stall one of the many
millions of faceless small kids working
at eateries
we encounter every day our cry project
partners excuse me had to work very long
and very hard to convince his parents to
let him get back to school and also get
his family government-issued ration
cards and identity cards to help them
access government schemes for food and
employment
and this amazing child who would have
carried on serving tea for clueless
punters like me this bundle of potential
and possibility within their year of
rejoining school he goes and invent
something that wins a national prize he
figures that the way his school cooks
his midday meals makes him and his
classmates cough and splutter so he
tinker's about and goes to science fairs
and then he invents a new cooking method
he uses raw material like toasted
coconut shells cellulose lime powder and
Erica crisps powder parentheses
exactly what I would have done of course
all the school in his district now use
this cooking method and they report far
more cost efficiency in far less
pollution and he goes on to win a
national award for it from the Ministry
of Science and Technology but that is
not all he is now an Ashoka youth
venture selected by the Ashoka youth
venture program that identifies and
supports the world leading social
entrepreneurs he has been recognized for
being a leader among the youth for
changing the way his community views
child labor and child marriage this this
is what hope looks like and changed
looks like this is what every child can
do if given a chance and this is what
our future can be we just have to want
it enough really really incredible
inspiring story of Naveen and what cried
this charity accomplished I just thought
that was really cool so I wanted to
share it with you guys so this is the
kind of impact than donating will have
so I think that's really dope
96 almost 97 Jesus amazing you guys are
absolutely crushing it
I am salute man Lance love from
Bangladesh thanks guys
do not love Sonia are you like teasers
music I don't I don't think maybe I
should actually listen to the music I
don't know I'm sure that I'm sure it's
good they're big for a reason obviously
show top donations at times
right I should actually talk about this
cuz notch Marcus person he I always see
him donate to charities I didn't expect
him to do any to this one but I think
that's really cool that he donated so
much as well I messed this up
thank you very much not for looking
after the Indian brush mark always such
a terrible guy donated ten thousand
crazy always so happy that he's being
supported he's been supportive all the
charity events I've done three X X X
Games three thousand goddamn I don't
know what three X X X Games is but I'll
have to check it out thank you very much
huge respect for anonymous for donating
a thousand John Wong a thousand Raj
Singh eight hundred Michael Forrester
five hundred amazing I don't know why it
keeps changing oh I know why because I
have it on auto refresh miss MA see what
happens
okay let me know if your music school
scuse me
I just Nathan Peng and Nicholas
Fitzgerald Rider
[Music]
will you take any of the money no I will
not take any of the money it will not
even go through me there will not be any
any I won't touch it I'm talking to cry
and I know GoFundMe reached out to make
sure that they just get the money
directly it's annoying because usually
you can donate the money directly but I
had to do to go fund me for myself
because their charity was enlisted and I
really like cry so I wanted to set it up
but this works perfectly you donate by
going here I don't know how I missed
that up go fund me.com slash mothers and
they should do that
[Music]
yeah it's Ling now Sherman
I mean we had a thousand hundred
thousand god damn you guys are amazing
ever thought of playing roblox like
every day every single day love from
Mike SIA
Thank You Marcia so case we did it four
times over
am I gonna play some games yeah yeah
definitely I mean I have a long a long
time to fill I just I feel weird like if
we're doing a charity stream and I just
jump into games right away
[Music]
try not to swear please try not to swear
challenge livestream I think I'm okay
I've gotten pretty good at not swearing
we'll see if that becomes a meme later I
thought we could play oblivion because I
really really really want to play
oblivion and I'm starting like I don't
know I never feel like it am I gonna
play four at night yes I'm actually
planning to play for at night but when
I'm let's just say I'll play for at
night when things are real desperate
this is just mouse not the time oh yeah
oblivion baby
[Music]
okay so for those who don't know we're
raising money for cry and amazing
charity that works to help children in
India one one of the things I didn't
talk about in my video because they I
just talked about child labor but they
also do focus on girl child which
basically means that in India from birth
child garlis are not as welcomed
sometimes they are discriminated
humiliated and not treated fairly which
means they also myth sometimes miss out
on health care and education and cry
this charity also works to break this
myth and educate people around this
issue but also ensuring state
accountability for this issue to make an
impact and the reason why I picked cry
out of charity already charities was
they actually work on the root cause to
fix these problems and not just putting
a band-aid over over these issues so I
think it's a really cool charity that
can actually make a lot of difference so
I know we're making a difference with
this icing I think is really cool we
need 80,000 printers well apparently he
could have done it he couldn't donate it
he could have hacked eight hundred
thousand
[Music]
that would have been epic no actually
I'm glad he didn't do that sometimes I'm
legit worried that someone's gonna do
something crazy in the name of subscribe
to PewDiePie and I'm just gonna look
like an idiot
okay this is epic okay that's a dead
meme coming from me
what's that what should I do in the next
meme review by the way I don't I haven't
really followed in these I know one you
should have two or three you want to be
tracer - done you mean you're right have
you guys heard of surgery in a grape but
they did surgery a grape
how freaking crazy is that I cannot
believe they did surgery on a grape that
mean was not funny even when it came out
oh yes bright cranberry is good
cranberry the berry memes continues what
if mr. B's donates my god I didn't even
think of that he would have to donate
like a million I know mr. B's mentioned
in one of his videos that he wanted to
like get a visa for India or something I
wonder if he's planning anything more I
actually don't know loving the
background music me too it's so good I
like how you guys are telling me all
these memes you know they're gonna die
right if I if I'd review them
am i uploading today yeah I'll probably
could uses as a tax write up I'm not
touching any of the money it's going
directly to what to charity
[Music]
thanks for everything you do thank you
guys thanks for all the donations Jesus
Christ we've already erased the raised
raise when is that over thirty thousand
good job guys
I'm seriously so proud of you guys this
is Toby Fox hit a hip shop the song in
the background
will we see mine say again never
if you leave YouTube you you never ever
ever entered the Internet no Rhian wiser
were planning to shoot a video together
but then realize it didn't work as well
the reasons but she's definitely gonna
be part of my channel like the way I've
we always done hit or miss I guess they
never miss huh oh yeah that's some new
meme with that new song [ __ ] I forgot
what it's called it's like a tick tock
mean I might look into that more it's
kind of funny I'm amazed
tick tock is still in in the in the game
goddamn blessed
what if T series donated hmm let's check
everyone tweet T series to donate right
now I think that would be cool why not I
[Music]
can live stream again that's right I I
have my own leased line now let me show
it to you
[Music]
it took I think it took over a year it
must have taken over a year to get it
install and then they just put it on the
wall
it was so [ __ ] loud I'm like it's a
joke at least I have a good internet now
I used to have like zero point I don't
know like not even one [ __ ] make
megabit servers call things like zero
point seven or something now I have a
hundred it's amazing that's right I have
like five thousand in it I don't care
did I swear oh no damn it damn it I
didn't even realize every time two
swears he has to do that might be good
actually
don't sweat now all the [ __ ] pigs have
legs no I actually had this program in
OBS that CGI's legs for me I was
actually rolling my sitting there you
know that's not funny play the crab song
I'll play the crab song when we hit the
donation' ball
play pub G dead games I don't know I got
kind of bored with the pub G it's a fun
game but it's all about for at night
okay I freaking love for tonight
I play for night every day play the
guitar it's not tuned although the one I
have in the other room is you're wearing
headphones you goddamn right I'm wearing
headphones why wouldn't I
I need to collab with Gloria Borger
that's a great idea ever thought of a
replacing cry of fear that makes me
[Music]
that's right if you don't need to cry
you are actually respecting ready
because you were helping girls in India
another issue that I didn't really talk
about as much in the video because I
wanted to keep it kind of condensed but
malnutrition is a huge huge problem in
India they have the maximum number of
malnutrition children in the world so
one out of every three children is
malnourished I got this from their
website that's crazy so cry or this
charity that we're doing even for check
out up there they work to help mothers
even before the the child is born to
during their pregnancy and make sure
they have a healthy pregnancy to stop
this and combat this making sure that
children get proper health care but of
course making sure to know the children
get nutrition as well they they sent me
another story actually that I thought
was really
but I thought was really inspiring let
me read it for you
[Music]
it's a look it's a little it don't judge
you from the first picture because I'm
gonna add in a couple so there you go
there's after and this is what the
charity will to me this makes no sense
it's this weird edits in my face
sometimes happiness is as simple as just
looking at three pictures
it was realizing that change is possible
that miracles and transformations do
happen in humble but meaningful ways
so the first image is that of a severely
malnutrition child in one of our cry
project areas in the tribal region of
bundelcund district of Madhya Pradesh
cry has worked long and hard with the
community to revive the long-forgotten
tribal diet as long as in middle rich in
nutrients using locally available plants
and grains the community grows leaves
and contributes them free to the local
daycare centers so that the children's
nutrition needs are well looked after
the second picture is Vega is all the
nutrient-dense things that the community
traditionally used to eat which our work
has helped revive again it's not exactly
I'm not sure exactly what those four
Ghana grains and boots and barks are
exactly but damned they do look pretty
and boy do they do great things pretty
good I guess how amazing is it when
things like this happen and how proud we
are when we enable a community to look
after its own children there have been
no cases of malnourishment in the eight
villages and the under this product area
at all for the past
miracles do happen sometimes all it
takes is a little going backwards in
time to help move ahead so this child is
an example of the impact that this
charities have and that's where your
money and donation actually goes forward
to making a positive impact for India
really cool to see actual the actual
differences that charities have done so
yeah if you want to support this cause I
highly appreciate it and I recommend
doing it and check out GoFundMe comm
there or link is in the description
we're at 115,000 god damn amazing work
guys I'm so proud so cool keep it up
boys and girls and everyone did I see
the virus article attacking my thing
maybe I didn't read it right but it
seemed like they were attacking feel
like they just think it's all they have
to tell about all the controversies like
a checklist I'm so used to it
[Music]
epic collabed with t-series I mean if
you can't beat them I'm pretty sure they
they want nothing will say yeah all
right should we should we fire up some
games it's been 40 minutes seems fair
let me see here
this is for let me know if anything is
too loud good job Bethesda good job
can't even launch you know I hear stuff
but my screen is just dead hit
copyrighted music I don't think it is oh
there we go again
look at that
[Music]
people in socialblade are so toxic until
latter units thank you very much I'm
glad we're all doing this
[Music]
Oh oblivion what nani deskah
oblivion sama ah Kuwaitis nee oblivion
is the greatest game ever made you
goddamn right I never played it I know
it says continueed it make it seem like
I have played I haven't played a rag
click new and then ok Chava shut up oh
my god that is the ugliest screen I have
ever seen in my life is that how old the
loading screen looks like I was born oh
my god that's the ugliest man I've ever
seen for 65 years I've ruled this
Tamriel remember when this game came out
but for all these years 500 years ago
ruler of my own dreams I'm gonna be
swimming until 7 o'clock
else I don't look at me soca Libya
beyond which no waking I may see behold
in more doors but do me switch the lab
wow that looks really original but this
is PewDiePie
this game looks great whoa look at that
Wow yeah it's very Lord as soon as it's
quieter saying the last seed that's a
big tower 433 can you climb that these
are the closing days of the third era
and the final hours of my life are there
any bridges in Oblivion oh god oh god I
see so many such a [ __ ] unfunny me
[Music]
that's a golden tower uncultured swine
oh I'm sorry
[Music]
how was I supposed to know that I swear
again damn it you swore language you
don't control me
it's that Patrick Stewart it couldn't be
I don't think I swore okay I'm pretty
sure I did oh my gosh oh my god what is
that watch your profanity
all right first comment the next donator
will be the name of this of this
character can I actually check that
let's see what it refreshes Henry fine
Henry learn it is everybody what a great
name I can't type oh okay just Henry as
a dumb name as it is I'm kidding Oh God
you you this is a furry game huh oh god
you can't see me [ __ ] sorry yeah how do
I live stream guys but I can't tap out
where's my mouse there it is okay there
we go oh I do not swear what did I swear
now shut up that's not what are you
talking about this is a horror game yeah
Jesus Christ don't look at me like that
all right Rosie Nord that's what I'm
talking about
Nord I don't like how they appropriate
my rage like this okay you can have the
cat's or you can have the Nords okay and
you can have the jacksepticeye's that's
fine get it because it's green stop
swearing No
how much what
let's get to spray oh boy how many
gender options good one okay yeah
Oregonian Bratton what the hell is a
Bratton looks just like noir doesn't it
have you heard of the high Alps Wow all
right who should I pay the Breton's are
the most boring race Wow
racist Dark Elves it looks so ugly high
off looks kind of funny catchy this is
like what happened Argonian Argonian
because you're a reptile Thanks okay
fine how old
okay apparently you go green for a while
if you're Argonian we have an old
Oregonian I kind of like that like this
makes any difference no no no no I know
you can make more changes yeah give me a
nerd no no no are you kidding me lizard
confirms
cool now we just got to watch that again
this isn't happy wheels oh I'm sorry I
was born yeah yeah we don't care what is
this can you not customize their
argonians is that what happened oh there
it is it was up okay so race Argonian
not furry Argonian that's right there
you go so you can just adjust the hair
there you go
face got it okay okay okay look at that
chin leave for you style ha oh damn
a thick Argonian I like that oh yeah oh
oh oh oh I can remove how can we make
something really ugly already ugly you
know what I mean I don't even know if
that's possible that's pretty thick
I don't know man as much as I want to be
an Argonian you're kind of like Oh God
anything you would save the settings my
god they look so unhappy I'm sorry Jesus
Christ dude all right fine okay it's
kind of cute
all right now we're a rare each in
that's oh my god yeah I like that that's
cute
that's definitely cute you know duck
face
we hit 120,000 donations amazing thank
you guys for donating the link is in the
description every little bit that you
guys want to donate to this charity it's
very much appreciated and you are making
it an impact I'll go through more every
once in a while okay so now I already
adjusted this nice eyes big eyes that's
right
far apart as possible that's that's the
most attractive way to do it that's why
I like Marcia her eyes are just so far
apart
okay I don't know if I can they had a
lot of customization back then I
remember when I play like a skate game
when I was a kid and you can have like a
boob slider and I thought that was like
the best thing ever
so if what's game is oblivion it doesn't
have that I'm gonna be very very
disappointed constantly sad yes that's
how you want to look like skate three
was the best goddamnit they need to make
an unescapable meting make something
good ea please we want you back oh my
god you can adjust so much this is crazy
you can really
I guess that's the thing that we're
going to be oh look at this dude oh my
god I this is too good
oh yeah Bretton was the most boring race
oh my god hey it's Michael Jackson oh
that chin Dan Nord okay fine I'll be
Nord that's too cute oh my god
86 years later and maybe we'll start
playing okay sorry
kind of like Shorthair hey look you can
be effeminate just kidding how you can
change the hair oh that's good I like
that oh that's good
that's kind of cute I don't buy you guys
but I actually want to look good yeah
what is that
oh-ho-oh can you get Majan this guy's
sneaking up on you at night this is the
only part of the game I'm happy beard
where oh oh oh oh oh my god okay
I think that's it Henry I'm sorry but
I'm gonna name and sell an ass because
that's the greatest name of all time all
right I think we're ready there we go
here it is this is the game this is the
game incredible oh that's great
oh yeah I'm enjoying this game what a
beautiful character
can I pick stuff up jump whoa fits the
sky amazing it's not crowbar and it's a
bone again block okay cutting-edge aura
polygons thick AE I see what you did
there Z let's see move things
ha ha we're talking to me bend steel can
you boy yeah all right the big muscles
thank you and this beautiful face
[ __ ] I don't like this guy yeah
how do I say am I sitting oh yeah I'm
sitting guys look
this game is grow Magazine oh they were
I was sitting oh my god look at this
guy's
this changes everything my job right now
is to get you to safe oh my god I looks
oh god is king Oh what's up doing here
this Sun is supposed to be off-limits
usual mixup with the watch you can look
at it like stand back prisoner he won't
hesitate to kill you if you get in our
way
okay let me turn oh god it's terrifying
get them away if you prisoners stand
aside over by the window stay out of the
way and you won't get hurt
president stand away from the door over
by the window now I am I'm sitting down
dude calm down
get over by the window now oh god oh god
I don't like seeing him can't look stay
put prisoner good let's go we're not out
of this yet okay you I have seen you now
God it's my dad let me see your face you
are the one from my dreams then the
stars were right that my child I believe
it is is the day God's give me strength
what the hell's going on attacked my
sons and I am next my blades are leading
me out of the city and by chance the
entrance to that escape route leads
through your cell Sean Bean is it really
no okay I am your Emperor Uriel Septim
by the grace of the gods I serve Tamriel
as her ruler that's a lot Romania la
solana citizen eater
l and you too why my stance the gods
have placed you here so that we may meet
as for what you have is this Chiron yes
this is Darrin - actually that is not
what you will be remembered for t-series
will win oh yeah well are they winning I
don't think so
what should I do you will find Europe ok
don't care very you say we must keep
moving I don't like how this guy looks
at me that's my bank break what happens
if I move out say hey sorry I'm sorry
I'm sorry I can take it like that
you're lucky I'd live on what have I
done that's so likable hey come back
you're coward how do i this doesn't
concern you prisoner a dust you walk
through my bed
where am I gonna sleep listen I don't
need your abuse I get enough from it all
day in comments cyberbullying your magic
eyes protect the Emperor Oh No protect
the Emperor I thought you liked me I
thought you liked alright you know what
Jesus Christ well that was the end of
salad ass adventure number one Sarah
definitely won victory is there a death
run 123,000 great job guys keep it up
rowdy
oh wait what damn that's fabulous look
at that Oh get out and stay out of the
way yes that's how you pick up Oh God
look away sorry how do I lose my
equipments take you ok how do I open
them we're playing Skyrim two guys there
we go
do we have a katana what that's epic
hey what geez says that goddamn rats
guess we're going this way maybe we had
some money play Skyrim i am playing
skyrim it's a shield can I have that
whoa aah
bet you wish you had this loser ha Jase
what's wrong with you I don't have
lockpicks maybe it was just trying to
warn me the door is locked
okay all right fine I cannot see
anything good lockpicks in here rat me
that sounds delicious oh cool we have
armory there it is lockpick
okay cool oh god please stop looking at
me please stop
oh damn I'm ripped why my blue why am i
blue shirtless it'sh oh hell yeah
sorry but this is very hypnotizing it's
got a very good posture I feel like
I don't think I caught that so we're
just launched a lockpick all right so
how does this work very easy but I can't
seem to do it how was that not yet am I
actually being really stupid right now
again move to goblin shamans anyway oh
my god
oh I have to click okay okay shut up oh
that's not a swear is it no it is oh god
more rants HTC no just kidding no more
of that um okay
see I'm doing really good at this I feel
like I could definitely go from torch
okay definitely wanted to watch how many
don't even ask if you gotta ask you know
you already
where is the torch I drank
I don't know wait what game is this
Skyrim - we're playing Skyrim - gross
whoa Jesus why is everyone against me
rat me yummy delicious I hope there's no
bridges take your shield up
why I'm gonna die oh my god
thank you for the tip game of the year
it's escape three yesterday's goddamn
right it's skate three oh my god oh my
skill increased by a rat eating on my
ass
thank you very much Riley you want some
rats don't think so don't think you
don't think oh cool there's a helmet now
I can cover up my ugly face
stupid rats man okay say goodbye to this
face boys oh god you can still see it
this game is better than for like 76
you goddamn Ryan today I never actually
played it I don't have time to play
games he says while playing games is
that the Red Dead Redemption - game yeah
it is we're in the cowboy area right now
where all the Cowboys are
oh is that a barrel freakin barrels how
dare you Congrats on 74 million thank
you very much
we almost head-on in 25,000 that's
amazing oh gosh
one hit boy I almost said [ __ ] but that
would have been a swear word so I didn't
say it okay I don't care what is this
[Music]
damn so it's a game like have I been in
the game now or this is how it works
barrels Tom and Tom beforehand tongue
that their father nice eight
oh my god it's uglier than me look at
those nipples
god damn slice right through them this
is a legit game guys oh why would you do
that to right
oh god I hear someone oh shoot
this guy's strong never mind I'm
stronger don't even try me bros it's a
stream gonna be uploaded after it's done
ah depends I don't really know why you
want to rewash this this is the greatest
footage of all time I get it
although it is my first playthrough of
the Libyan which I'm very excited about
this is part 1 out of 500 am i walking
two circles that 125 gay we did a whoa
amazing we're only 25 God how dude why
would you do that oh oh oh I didn't even
mean to I'm sorry I'm sorry
oh why I'm so sorry case you're so
goddamn ugly
I know spread the ugliness across the
world okay that's my quest that's my
goal
Iren arrows
your death will not be in vain my have
reframes oh god stop please stop
Felix did an oopsie all right cheeks no
katana buck katana amok what do you got
katana why a cantana wat what do you got
the time
are you lost now you don't know how to
deal with katana block don't think so
don't think so you may be ugly
you're not my friend sneak skill
I wasn't even sneaking look at the head
they're still coming I guess you get to
sneak Johnson if you're a loser all
right where's the exit of this place oh
dude okay okay let's do all god please
weapons okay guys let's knock em over
Epis you won't know a thing is shooting
lightning no straight don't help flow
[ __ ] shoot stop stop
I swear to god I'm gonna be sick okay
alright
Plan B climb path okay don't play change
[Music]
oh I'm crouching that's why we're so
slow I thought he would die that's what
you get
shame on you I thought he put like a
spell on me to make me slower that's why
I was [ __ ] just go just go just go
pathetic pathetic you're all pathetic
goddamn I'm good at this game
god damn it's like I was born in this
game livestream is this he'll even aloud
while my copyright strike disappeared
25th of November so I'm Gucci boys I can
live stream can you be cannibal in this
game why would I eat anything that looks
like this you tell me
alright surely look at that hey guys
it's me hello hello it's me hello I'm
back why are you attacking me what the
Frick that is that isn't he is not one
of them
oh he known help us he must help us yes
Daddy they cannot understand why I trust
you they've not seen what I've seen
oh really how can I explain listen you
know the nine how they guide our fates
with an invisible hand yes of course the
night I've served the nine all my days
and I trust my course by the sleight the
nine are honest this guy is a marked
with numberless sparks each a fire and
every one a sign
I know these stars well and I wonder
which sign marked your
the Fox oh okay so I get to pick now
okay okay okay
well obviously I'm the snake cuz I'm a
snake
the lady the lady's blessing bonuses
well power and endurance magic the
[Music]
poison touch and stuff okay I feel like
this is kind of important stuff that you
pick early a lot of North lesser power
to regenerate up to you're also getting
the troll akin curse weakness to fire
that sounds like I can scroll oh oh I
see okay okay there's even more damn the
steed speed well why should I pick then
don't pick the serpent you oh good one
the steam is Pawar's I don't know what
that means
where's the link to donate I'll shoot
it's not on the screen it's really one
second guys okay there it is
case you're looking for him we are now
at 126 thousand it's getting there
thank you everyone for all this report
you're done so far amazing
oh this is the cry website is down
GoFundMe should still be up so you can
still you can still donate towards the
charity maybe we don't go in the cry
website right now cuz I don't want their
website to go down picked raiser
there's no tracer in here what am I
gonna pick then
[Music]
I'm already tracer someone already
picked tracer are you kidding me shadow
be edgy alright fine the signs I read
show the end of my path by death a
necessary end will come when it will
come
try to kill the Emperor you all stop
alright don't care don't care now
can I kill him what happens if I kill
him you may as well make yourself useful
carry that torch and stick close okay
I'm sitting close so let us do our job
you were right I am an SI see this how
does he not yes what the hell what just
happened I swear I saw him
okay cool I guess they're fine with a
for some reason
yeah you're doing a great job protect
the Emperor one guy attacks that's fine
protect the Sura
oh my god
this one's mine protect the Emperor damn
I can jump really high oh dude I can get
a skirt no wait hey oh god stop every
time were you looking at me hey is that
a chest weak potion what's that
feels weird playing games on livestream
it's been so long how's it going hold up
I don't like this let me take a look
acro bike skills increase you see that
you see those moves sewers is this a
puzzle no just going here no I think an
open it damn it
the gate is bought from the other side a
trap what about that side passes back
there you swerve a try
let's go ok I already checked it out
guys don't worry
it's a dead end what's your closer my
god what are they doing wait here sire
wait here with the Emperor guard him
with your life why should i why should i
were they going I think it's time for
you and me to have a long have a little
chat I can oh Jesus
you alone must stand against the Prince
of destruction and his mortal servants
wise not take the amulet give it to job
find him and close shut the jaw okay
this is so sad
look at that guy's there was a passage
over here oh god I'm gonna go soon I'm
gonna go it wasn't me it wasn't me it
wasn't me I swear to God I would never
hurt him we have a veiled yeah yeah yeah
me don't care okay
alright don't care thank you I get to
pick something else okay
Acrobat I feel like I was really good at
Acrobat skills it's a cool art I like
this art style
specialization magic magic might be fun
sorcery might be fun
intelligence oh that's me cool
done where's ork really yeah yeah
I am you good okay I was care sorry I'm
really rude
he's fine look he's fine he's a lie
look he moved okay let's go
Jesus every time okay
oh I have the key now we press this
button oh it's the sewers ah god damn it
Oh f5 is quick saying thanks guys well
game is for the 500 millionth time at
Skyrim for deluxe edition the finished
edition athletic skill increase what did
I just do that was just planning my god
I don't have that stop what are you
doing
wait for me guessing this is long Thank
You Garrett thank you very cool they if
I see anyone comment did the surgery on
anything you're paying for life look we
found it finally okay yeah sure anything
you do I just start off with spells oh
look at this
yay the red point in your map is where
we need to go okay that's cool
this is amazing look at this the
graphics in this games incredible my
crunching again all right so where's my
skeleton I can use skull that's critical
spell rond Garmin time run eater of rat
meat it slips off your neck as you try
to fasten it around your neck okay
sounds a very epic all right we've been
let me just take a break there because
that reason why we're here the reason
I'm doing this live stream where is my
mouth
sounds very dramatic with this
background music the reason why we're
doing this charity is to raise money for
crying which is a charity that helps
kids in India we're helping nine year
olds in India and your donation is
helping every little bit is counting we
already may raise an incredible amount I
didn't think we'd get anywhere near the
goal this nice dream it looks like we
could actually hit it
I'm social proud of you guys thank you
so much for all the donations so far
let's have a look at it sounds so
dramatic with the background
June 1 2007 Oh 3,000 even
our real 6 thanks guys that's my
management thank you guys that's very
nice Oh No
[Music]
this is the left yeah there we go
[Music]
Thank You John Lee thank you rich the
King thanks everyone
it's amazing
wasn't that with market play yeah micro
player doing it in it's amazing yeah
notch donate as well sorry I already
mention it I assume that everyone so
watch the whole thing it's really
amazing so yeah for those who you don't
maybe jumped in or maybe you haven't
watched we're raising money for a cry
which is a charity that helps kids in
India they focus on many different
things but one one of the major ones and
the reasons why I wanted to pick this
charity was because child labor is a
huge issue in India ten point three
million between the age of five to
fourteen I mentioned this in my video so
so young so many kids are under child
labor in India you don't think about it
and this is mainly in rural areas and 23
million between the age of 15 and 18 so
one in every 11 children in India is
under child labor I just thought that
was insane and to fix that problem it's
not as easy as just forcing or there's
really no one thing to fix it because as
I mentioned before there's a high demand
for cheap labor and people can these
kids need to do it a lot of times to
help their families so it's not so easy
but cry the charity that we're raising
funds for the way they deal with it is
focusing on the root issue instead of
just helping one child really making
sure to make an impact which is one of
the reason like I said to that I picked
cry it feels weird saying cry cuz every
time I say cry I imagine cry so what
what cry do it now I ruin it for myself
what they do is they interact with
parent community leaders and discuss
these damaging effects and what they
actually cause to create an impact and
make a change for the generations to
come and education is another huge issue
in India because so many of the kids
choose to not go to school because they
they
are forced to either work instead and
one out of four children are of
school-going age is out of schooling in
yet which is not a very good number
it's illiteracy is a big problem in
India as well and cry works to make sure
that kids stay in school and don't have
to face issues that set them back in
life from the start I wanted to so this
is where your money is going towards
this is where your donation is going for
it's a great cause and because like I
mentioned in my video as well because a
lot of these t-series stuff became about
almost like India versus I don't know
the rest of the world I thought that was
stupid so I'm really glad we're making a
positive change for India I think it's
really cool I'm really proud of you guys
I wanted to read another story that was
really really inspiring which was sent
to me by cry the charities let me pull
it up here it is from this young girl on
the screen there you can see in right
now
let make sure to check if they send me
any one second okay perfect so this is
what cry their charity wrote me it's a
story about this girl in quotation mark
the path from dream sorry the path from
dreams to reality does exist this is
from Kalpana Chawla astronaut and first
female of Indian origin in space these
words always inspired mood through mood
too
I really hope I say this right move -
whaa - I'm sure that's not correct but
with through men Oran Genie which is the
girl on the screen when she read about
Kalpana Chawla in her high school
textbook she wanted to be exactly like
her someone who despises
being a girl from a small town India had
managed to reach for the stars the only
problem was that for ranjani' the path
from dreams to reality was a far harder
one to traverse she belonged to the
community of manual scavengers who for
generations have cleaned human waste
thanks to cry her parents found all
alternate professions and as and as if I
can't read and as if the first person in
her family to go to school
Ranjini felt that she had her world at
her feet an excellent school a student
in school Ranjini kept at her dream and
worked hard and decided that she wanted
to become an aeronautical engineer
unfortunately her parents felt that it
was a male-dominated profession and
didn't agree
till cry stepped in again to counsel her
parents to allow her to follow her heart
today run Jeannie's parents are her
staunch staunchest supporters and why
shouldn't they be their brilliant
daughter a first generation learner has
won the prestigious gold medal medal for
topping her college course when asked
what her future plans are she replies
without batting an eyelid she's going to
become an astronaut like Kalpana Chawla
for someone whose family for generations
including her parents man you knew
manually cleaned human waste from dry
latrines and sewers renjini has come a
long way and is definitely aiming for
the sky just from her own from her
little community and from surrounding
villages that cry works with there are
more than a hundred girls who are in
professional colleges today from a
situation a few years back when there
wasn't even a single girl in high school
the path from dreams to reality does
exist sometimes all it needs is a few
determined young women and a little help
from cry true Traverse a really really
amazing inspiring story about this girl
so this shows some of the stuff that
they work with they they don't just
focus on
one issue for example so this is why
we're doing this cause and I think it's
really really cool like wait where is it
like I mentioned in know I like I didn't
mention in my in my video was that they
also work with to help young girls
because apparently I didn't know this
but birth from birth girls in India or
not as welcomed as men and they often
get discriminated humiliated and not
treated fairly just like what happened
to her and sometimes even miss out on
health care and almost missing out on
education which does not happen here so
cry works to break these myths that
people in ideas that people have about
girls in India and also ensure that
doing different things as well to me
like the state for example make sure
that they have accountabilities around
these issues as well as so I think
that's really cool in a really really
inspiring story I'm really proud of you
guys and everyone for donating so
there's someone make a 15000 Nations I
read that but I don't think that's true
now it isn't where we had 136 though
didn't it just shoot out I don't know
where respect when respecting young men
it's really cool
I just want to make sure I don't miss
any okay
I missed a 3k donation they don't know I
read Oh Neil Saunders eight minutes ago
that's what I missed
Neil Saunders donated 3000 that's
incredibly generous
thank you very much Neil that's white
shut up okay that's cool amazing
thanks Jay everyone every little bit
helps as well every piece that you
donate really really cool we're so close
to our goal as well I think that's
amazing I'm so glad we're doing
something positive for India I think
that's so cool
turn this whole thing around I'd be so
proud if we hit the goal I'm not ending
no we got another hour and a half at
least crab song at goal Thanks goddamn
right
all right guess I'm keep playing
oblivion yeahit's listen listen you need
to break it up a love that feels so
weird playing games I don't know why
it's a thing to do games and charity but
I guess he works for the nine-year-olds
excuse me
honestly this game looks pretty good
it's got a comfy feeling to it your
acrobatic skills have increased yeah why
do I have a torch out in the daylight
find out more questions and answers so
I'm supposed to go to the red arrow
through this many motions sake is so
weird
142 now what the Frick happened
god damn crab song intensifies
someone donate three is six can somebody
say where's my
[Music]
mr. bees thank you very much mr. beast I
was wondering when you would show up
[Laughter]
technically we already hit the goal
because they're one of my donations is
on the other stream and I'm gonna merge
them eventually that's amazing
that's so funny mr. Beebe's god damn
angel thank you very much
I bet he's trying to like leave some
message like if you if it is my mr. B's
impression if you don't if you donate
five thousand if I don't like that you
have to do a barrel you have to punch a
barrel sorry mr. B's you can't leave any
messages maybe they've been judging him
really hard right now he's just trying
to help mr. B's to the race where would
I be without mr. B's guardian angel of
this of this channel alright can I go in
again
very closely to go I feel like I should
put away my sword because otherwise
they're gonna freak out this is me and a
torch this is me in a do so got nothing
teach what I do know know what do we
have hey cotton the acted then pet okay
what are you gonna do what are you
possibly going to do what are you
possibly going to do what could you
possibly do to me out huh what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do
Oh God brofist the sky listen I didn't
do anything I'm innocent I respect women
too much please
ha you'll never get me here maybe you
know what maybe I shouldn't have
punished that woman in the face just a
thought
just a thought she was the first one
that attacked me
I got scared greetings to you we're
playing Skyrim number 5 here it's a
really cool game hundred and forty-four
goddamn Hey look they got mushrooms
okay so according to the map I'm
supposed to go here advice is writing
out a code did you know parity PI maybe
you took will ban me oh I just got a
message so Neil Sounders that donated
3000 is from clutch chairs I should have
recognized that
thank you very much Neil hey 319 citizen
3000 that's amazing
what Sharon's has been so nice to work
with they stuck with me through
thickened and whatever the expression is
just like you guys I can fast travel now
why would I do that
3000 pounds even some pounds here guess
we're going this way dude it's like so
far away just fast travel okay okay by
the way fast travel you cannot travel
while in air why not why not which one
did I press that's to be one of these
buttons which button is it
[Music]
you like Jax if you donate 399 will they
get a check yes
all right which one is that M format
nothing's happening
I swear I'm pressing in need to unlock
the flight / tab menu f4 I'm not praying
it blessing anything f4 you can't troll
me
be careful in the bridge shut up shut up
you know what
which one is Auto walk there you go okay
just to make sure I need to get it drink
I mean a I did it
yeah oh you thought I couldn't do it
well you thought wrong
speak snowman and stop wasting my time
I didn't even say anything help help I'm
being it how are you saying help you
look super angry and mean I've got it
you've done it now Felix oh god I don't
want to cross the bridge again alright
listen I can get I can get oh god I just
want it oh I own that pants okay we can
do this we can do this we got lettuce
cut not today
you're showing you too much of your neck
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's what I
thought that's what I find now how do I
not walk so garden there we go um you
know didn't I not get rid of you
that's what happens when you criticize
me when I cross the bridge huh
that's sexy outfit there you had the low
neck shirt it's mine now
that's right it's mine I'm the sexy boy
now
now I'm gonna raid your house huh
what else do you got chairs don't make
me Chiefs amazing look is this where you
slept what an idiot
what an absolute idiot I hope this
teaches you guys to stop making fun of
me okay
cuz that's what freaking happens go to
sleep in the game why does something
happen
you cannot sleep while trespassing cool
thanks for the tip guys really really
good job what we need to go where's the
crime son why did no one tell me crime
songs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
what Ernie
so fast
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh really
[Applause]
[Music]
the boys in one day one day
[Music]
okay that's enough that's enough of the
crab amazing oh it's a noise storm just
search crab song you'll find it how much
money raised someone else it's right
there on the screen one hundred and
fifty two thousand but we're not
stopping here I said I was gonna live
zoom to seven o'clock so I might as well
just keep going there's no reason to
stop now if you want to keep donating
it's for a great cause is to have
children in India we're making a
positive impact this is so cool I'm so
glad we hit it really really proud of
you guys and now black back to oblivion
this is why everyone is here whoo yeah
I'm donating as well I donate five
thousand I'm gonna donate more I just
can't do it on the GoFundMe page because
they don't take my credit card and I
just created last minute but I can do it
on the other campaign all right so where
do I go now then
go to sleep in the end next to you is
that our fast travel by sleeping yes of
course that's how you do it Felix okay
we want to go to Bruma what do you want
no what do you want what do you want
what do you want what do we have what
did I do to pay your fine what did I do
when for skating your stolen goods I
didn't do anything then pay with your
blood then you can suck my balls oh I
killed a guy oh yeah like that's a big
deal get out of here I'm done and then
you cannot arrest me you cannot arrest
me me it is not it's not gonna happen
buddy it's just not gonna you got a
friend now this is cheating the leap
system32 yet that'll do it
come on 150 mm Wayne stopping here boys
can you leave me alone oh god oh god
they're catching up aren't they
II that'll do it that'll do it I got you
I'm just trying to get out of here I
didn't ask for anything I didn't ask for
anything I didn't ask for anything
please leave me do they actually stop
put away your sword oh it makes me
slower okay ah shoot wrong button I'm
burning up in here Mila oh my god the
rat saved me get him right
you run faster with a knife that has to
be a lie I cannot equip it what that
freak of fur is against me now know it
what is this
oh I run faster with a knife yeah I
don't think so buddy
I run faster with memes well that's that
leaves true stop Oh actually I'm pretty
good now
okay we'll make it out of this spruce
I've got open open open a chute
what the hell does that even mean
whatever ah when you are get married
tomorrow this is my bachelor party how
do I run with that legs I don't know
press hard to put away my weapon this is
what our does I think I made it no okay
we have a rival we're safe see serious
donate that would be amazing
here it is you guys said it was far dude
I did it so fast
Oh God all right see you I gotta talk to
you
my brother Jeffrey what do you want a
haircut I'm here to give you one this
cannot be no one but the Emperor is
permitted to handle the amulet let me
see it that's supposed to be like a
Swedish or like Nordic accent this
cannot be this cannot to happen here is
the amulet before the amulet of kings
your men deity how did you get this they
spend yard and cross on his death as
unlikely as your story sounds I believe
you it sounds like destiny of Uriel
Septim could have brought you to me by
the amulet of Kings shut their jaws I
definitely read that right the prince
how can I believe in our not sure
threatener only the Emperor the what all
right with Italy that the dragon fight
all right
they asked me to find his I am one of
the few who know of his existence okay
many years ago I served as captain one
night Uriel called me into his private
chambers
a baby boy lay sleeping in a basket
Uriel told me to deliver him somewhere
safe he never told me anything else
about the baby but I knew it was his son
from time to time he would ask about the
now okay I don't care about your son
Jesus Christ you're boring me alright so
now we got to deliver the Emily
somewhere else you must find welcome to
Wayne and prior me alone I'm busy Jesus
Christ give me a break is this guy not
stopped you have violated a law I didn't
even do anything bad
I swear T Sarah's fine here well then
you should leave this guy who's gonna
follow me the entire game why don't you
kill him can i all right
it's battle time it's time for this man
to show what he's capable of
it's time for this man to take a stand
for what he believes in take a stand to
fight for what he thinks is right and
eat some cheese cuz god damn it cheese
is delicious
look he's strong okay he's really strong
but I'm stronger I forgot he had the
furrier in alright okay now you know
what men never mind
you guys said I press are to take away
the weapon you guys are a bunch of liars
do you know that
oh Jesus I'm healed I'm healing f-f
Thank You vista sky baby
isn't it nice to watch an actual pro
play a game instead of an idiot that
doesn't know what they're doing I hate
that that's just the worst hundred and
fifty for god damnit Rose that's right
I'm bringing back gross
you're not nine year olds anymore okay I
think we're safe
we're actually safe oh they are they
look at there they are they're stuck by
the tree what is happening wait are they
fighting each other what is happening
wait what happened there he died what
happened to him what are they fighting
oh they kill each other oh my god please
please no no no why what do we have you
killed the man you killed him you know
what you know what this is why I saved
cuz I had a feeling he would do that all
right let's keep going on our journey
our epic quest to stop t-series in this
game I found hack dirt what a lovely
name of a town they're just climbing
sign
why not I have a bounty on my head
that's fine no one can stop this man
what am i drinking in my videos I
usually just drink sparkling water but
it's kind of late some drinking G fuel
oh my god
see Oh God even the wolves are against
me like what the Frick wolves I don't
want to kill you I don't wanna kill you
oldest trick in the book
oldest trick in the book ha you fell for
that idiot
what an idiot [ __ ]
stupid stupid this is why wolves aren't
dominating society
you stupid furries that's right oh yeah
take off the armor why all right I'll
take this I'll wear the skirt because I
look good
the spell is not healing you when what
is it doing help me sleep and get health
alright fine fine I'll find a is it a
human alright this seems like a good
place to sleep alright sorry
their bed anyone here there we go this
seems like good is anywhere to have a
little nap Oh God Jesus soundly for a
murderer that's good
you'll need a clear conscience for what
I'm about to propose
oh my god it's he serious what do they
want - I am Lucy in the chance a speaker
for the Dark Brotherhood in you you are
a killer taker of life a harvester of
souls
your work your death craft pleases the
night mother and so I come to you with
an authoring no kale appearing from the
tea to join our rather unique family
it's very cheerful and music for a
deadly proposal continued mr. La Concha
I find your etiquette refresh alright
let's hear it alright but I'm no matter
alright brew feel it yeah will kill drew
phew that's right a knife in the dark
new quests let's kill Rufio yeah send
Rufio to his death and through a field
brother
I don't like embrace you as family okay
alright so oh he can be invisible that's
epic this is a nice place I like what
they've done with this place this is a
great place really like seems like I
should be happy that I couldn't sleep in
this place yeah this is definitely my
kind of god it's dark I don't want to I
don't want it to be dark oh let's have a
little nap again let's sleep for like 10
hours it's a 7 p.m. are then it's
definitely gonna be dark okay so wait it
started okay make that you have heard
room I could you how do I change quests
like how do I pick my active quest
physic
which Isis blocked out wait where I come
from there we go
no it's not f-j thank you
no J doesn't work you click a tab menu
oh look here's all my spells cool yeah I
want to use spells and stuff that's much
more fun how do I use spells man I
shouldn't have skipped all our hairs
requests okay all right let's where is
that on the map
it's right here I'm not found the
location yeah can't you just look at the
controls I should probably do that
that's helpful
okay so block cast see
I know there's like a quick I thought I
would remember like I'm hold I know I
hold down okay that's that's that thing
summin skeleton ah damn that's cool turn
undead OH
clock is seven now oh [ __ ] I am actually
genuinely bad at this game
it's a Skyrim six that were playing epic
scrolls oh it's because I didn't wait
long enough I see so now it's 8 a.m.
okay I see
listen there's a lot to learn
alright let's go to the new location
yeah it's my first time that's right
you goddamn right I'm playing oblivion
and you goddamn right I'm terrible at it
120,000 people watching is it that many
thought it was 12,000 people watching
and I'm just playing oblivion Oh No why
am I doing this
[Laughter]
math yes there I used to study math at
college I wish my thing
good job me I don't want to kill you I
don't want to kill you I'm serious oh
wait wait wait
oh damn it I was gonna summon my
skeleton alright next time I'll summon a
skeleton and it will be epic don't worry
guys I know what I'm doing
we were at two hundred thousand at some
point why am I such an idiot
best gaming PC ever perceives to play
oblivion hey these graphics Hey look at
that lens flare you see that but you
can't do that hey look at that but you
can't do that but you can spawn our lens
flare
dude this game is great I agree now is
there anything I want to attack me
because I will spawn a skeleton and I'm
not afraid to tell him to do stuff
it'll make you rattle oh there we go
here we go okay okay okay okay flare
oh it's flare time eh eh eh eh eh eh eh
eh eh okay okay okay okay okay okay okay
okay okay all right okay okay Kay Kay
Cammy Cammy where do you go where do you
go where did you go oh god damn it
son of a gun got away all right fine
we'll keep going to our it's our crisis
this way I swear babies
damn it I missed ya no yeah yeah it hit
I didn't I'm okay
come back here yeah damn it I'm coming
for you
hahahahahaha Oh
goddammit rat yes mine might get away
from me
no I don't want to wait which button do
I pick stuff up with I know I can pick
up no no stop yeah oh damn that leg
sexy rat to me
very delicious vegans are disliking this
video it's a video game okay it's not
freaking real so lame so lame
all right
summon skeleton I'll be you son next
time someone attacks me hold II yeah
holy that works Zed
can I not lift him oh I'm late oh look
ice looking catcheth look Peeta he's
alive he's alive and he's fine he's just
with the nature thank you for rescuing
me Felix doesn't work it doesn't work at
all
ah I'm alive us around thank you ah
[Music]
nine-year-olds please donate Thanks
thank you so much
ah ah I'm so excited about this
livestream he's been talking about doing
live shoot for so long oh thank you my
controls are messed up I guess so hold
spacebar what does that do
[Music]
all right we're going to words like Oh
another one
okay now we can finally ow son of it
it's time for me to summon a special
move where'd he go oh stop I'm summoning
him I'm summoning him that's right my
good old friend mr. beast is here to
help me
thanks mr. Bies you're the best best
friends forever
dude you're freaking awesome I'm rattled
right now you look so radical I have a
bone to pick with you if you come here
all right he doesn't listen let's go
Thank You mr. beast very cool what's
happening mr. bass no and he's gone 156
the relations are still coming even
though we hit the goal that's amazing
let's keep going guys if you want to
donate up in the corner we're doing this
live stream for for crying an amazing
charity that helps children in India
Chiefs cry out can't speak we're making
a positive change we already did amazing
so let's keep going guys
[Music]
this is Skyrim 49 oh there is what the
hell where did you come from the funds
to pay the court you must now serve out
your sentence he has a he has a horse I
don't know if we can then pay God mr.
Bies please
mr. Bies mr. Bies don't do it alright
mister come on come on do it do it do it
now mr. beast get his horse oh it's my
the legend of salad ace the greatest
pirate there was ever been whatever the
meme is what an idiot
this is what happens when you miss no no
no you're coming with me horse oh I can
jump ok cool what complain more Jesus
right oh my god Pearce playing something
that's right video games everybody that
was an epic gaming moment guys I feel
really good about that all right do we
have to go through here anyone here a
goblet Oh
not on my watch mr. cobbling summon mr.
beast oh how did you hit me get him get
him get him get him get him get him get
him Jesus Christ whose a voice actor for
this no shoot okay we're gonna have to
spice things up them
don't you dare attack my horse are they
tight out no not my horse
don't kill my horse donkey Marsh don't
kill my horse donkey Mars you do not
kill horsie get away get away get away
get away get away great we're going how
everything is attacking me get him
horsey she says Christ like tiny little
jacksepticeye's terrifying Skyrim eight
everyone that's right I'm playing the
beta version all right there better be a
chest here because I I killed them all
and that was epic
then I worry a piss I see it I see it
all right first try okay second try I'll
do it on the second try Gil minor wounds
okay
alright alright here we go there it is
look at that first try and now we're
laying on the horse that's what I'm
talking about and that was the legend of
when you almost caught pewter pie
amazing no I'm not gonna wait I feel
like I'm doing pretty good we hit 162
someone surely made of another big
donations
I can't move my mouse Mike where's my
mouse there it is
highest D live TV D live thank you very
much delay that's awesome
very generous of you 5,180 thank you
very much d ly I appreciate you that's
really really cool crabs for D live
[Music]
well I guess I'll be streaming there
next time
alright that's amazing
still kicking it just realize oblivion
is probably less glitchy than fallout 76
has ever this cold follows everything
probably is this is not too bad I kind
of expected like glitches every five
seconds but so far there's been no
glitches horse got legs I know crazy
you found an in ill omen that seems like
a great place to just have a little
hello but have a little nap I need to
rest right oh my god alright are we cool
we're cool right hello stranger Jesus
doesn't get many visitors around here
I wonder why I wonder why he's lonely
for me it's not happening it's
definitely not happening certainly no I
didn't take any quest what is this know
what roofie to tell he doesn't all right
the only people Yeah right
till next time alright it's not
happening okay it's not happening
what does that mean oh hey take whatever
you want
hey take whatever you want what what hey
take what it hey take whatever you want
it's none of my business
[Music]
[Laughter]
it's tricky to maneuver I made such a
funny sound oh god I didn't know you
were there snow bear a customer oh my
god why are you guys surprised there's
customers got plenty of rooms if you
want one
ain't nobody staying can you be a little
less desperate please all roof roof you
guys that's the guy we need tell us Maya
Rufio he's an old codger all right I
don't care all right what about the bed
a bed well of course I'll take all right
okay oh this is a themed sign tell your
friends as always no one wants to go is
this my bed amazing I'm having a great
time here and the ill omen five stars on
Airbnb all right how do I do that
okay I don't want to do this I don't
want to this stop marster Ben what did I
pay him for are you kidding me
[Music]
[Music]
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do thief
what are you gonna do oh you took the
broom back you took the wine back you're
not even wearing pants dude dude dude
yeah I still got room Oh what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do what are you gonna do yeah
I still got room yeah you can still stay
I'm being robbed
farewell okay very well see ya
hey my trusty horse let's go alright
I was a great wizard wasn't it oh so
this is where he'll rue fear will come
so we should really just wait for Rufio
there's a second door upstairs to use
spoon hey don't call me a spoon okay
that's not freaking cool man okay fine
I'll go back all right but don't call me
a spoon no I already got what I wanted
haha a roux maybe I do need that alright
let me heal okay that's the second room
upstairs just don't call me a spoon not
freaking fall there how was I supposed
to see that wait that's the room I was
trying to get into
there's not a second room upstairs you
lure the spoons rufio is upstairs spoon
yeah I need Rufio shut up how do i lock
pick I don't understand like how am I
gonna get all them there's a hatch
[Music]
basement
you guys are must be drunk or something
alright first of all I can't see
anything where's my torches okay second
of all Rufio
go down okay I'm going oh oh oh
Rufio oh okay okay okay guys okay so
that's my room got it got it okay well
where's the Rufio then don't go there
scar Rufio
Rufio Sam we're asleep Rufio Rufio Rufio
raffia okay alright alright let's be
sneaky here
alright this is it this is it Bruce
Rufio is gonna frickin get it all he's
gonna get dag he's gonna get it boys
he's gonna freakin Guinea
okay Rufio
more like you're gonna lose see oh
you're gonna lose cuz you're gonna dying
Rufio all right there it is is Roo for
your time it's
raffia here
hey Rafi Oh Rafi oh he's Rufio
oh look at him sleeping Rafael are you
doing roof you huh let's see here
we got here Rufio what do we got here
come on Rufio what if we sleep with
Rufio can we sleep no he can't he's not
waking up is he
Rufio a Rufio someone's trying to kill
your roof you wake up Rufio
all right sorry Rufio but oh he we're
waking him up oh sorry
oh no how could you do this how could
anyone be so alright well damn Rufio
sexy we feel very attractive
alright a review you come with me The
Adventures of PewDiePie and Rufio all
right
actually this is close the door nothing
happened
nothing happened how do I get back up
you didn't see nothing
okay no one saw anything ah yes of
course now the quest continues actually
it's kind of dark I feel like I should
just go to sleep
yeah let's have a little nap see so now
it's 5:00 p.m. so we want to sleep
taller okay this is good
so no variac done the deed is done I'd
killed Rufio you will find that the Dark
Brotherhood knows a great many things
for you are now part of the family
Oh fam squad my life for the brother
indeed for the slaying of Rufio was the
signing of a covenant the manner of
execution your signature rufio's blood
Oh senator of the black let us all go to
the city of Jade in the Hall shading
Hall and an house near the eastern wall
okay that sounds that better the
basement
okay I'm to open the black door he
better not be naked in there cuz that's
gonna be weird okay all right you are
now one with the Dark Brotherhood chief
oh gosh I think they're onto me what
guys we have less on the actin no go
let's say you're fine listen I'm
confiscating your snow goods no first of
all first of all then pay with your
blood
second of all I like I didn't even even
care about you said you didn't care you
said you he's got a freaking giant
hammer stop stop stop
a sign step aside step aside our Jesus
crew listen where's my horse
goddammit oh there she is bye bye bye
don't think so don't think so losers you
can't stop me no one can stop me not
even teasing me and that's how it's done
everybody
easy The Legend of Rufio I wait I'm not
Rufio the legend of beautify who am I
please lowell 1290 bounty alright i
gotta be worth more than that fast
travel on map why would I when I have
this amazing horse and no one has told
me how to fast travel yet so how would I
how would I do that yes this is red dead
redemption for actually that we're
playing you're right oh yeah my horse
please guys please be gentle oh god we
gotta cross the bridge god dammit now
there's crabs don't did it did it did it
did didn't it fast travel were building
a gate for shut up shut up children oh
god this is a really narrow bridge this
is actually I'm actually scared on this
bridge okay we're going for it I think
there's a I got a pee really quick
your money or your life
[Music]
[Music]
what the hell is this Edgar
where is this
what happened wait y'all cast Jingle Jam
currently what is that I want to read
with us this is currently currently has
people recording an album 10 M I have a
link for that I'll check it out in a bit
but 76 looks so different what happened
here I don't have any money take it from
me if you can't I don't have any money
fine
this one will kill you or for free
always a highwayman ah I'm a highwayman
on the road again where are you going
me this is beautiful look at the
graphics in this game what is this what
is this oh god what's happening the draw
you draw power from the well oh dude I'm
getting power out please please t-series
I feel like I need a new horse wait
which one was mine that's his which
that's his okay
stop since you lack the funds to pay the
torch UI oh okay yeah okay
what are you gonna do you're gonna do
that okay you can never stop me no one
can
the your cast is rapping about me okay I
gotta see this goddammit
okay I feel like I might be good too
we've been playing a long time I'll just
I'll keep playing a little bit more
I do also kind of forgot just cuz we hit
the goal and I got so into the game what
game is is oh this is a legend of Skyrim
so for those of you who's dropping in
can't believe so many people are
watching I don't even realize that's
crazy
we did this charity to raise funds for
cry it's an amazing charity that helps
kids kids in India they make a big
impact and by donating you are making an
impact as well and I think it's so cool
that we're doing something positive for
India I'm really really proud that we
hit the goal by we're get we keep we
keep going we just keep going yeah this
is for Indian children all the money
will go directly to cry when the
campaign is finished it's an amazing
charity that actually does make a
difference so if you want to donate any
little bit we'll help
I really really appreciate it I think
it's really cool I'm so stoked that we
hit the goal Indian I'm your fan thank
you very much I saw a lot of comments
being appreciated as well they know I'm
joking like when I make jokes they
understand the humor but it was nice to
see that so many people appreciate it
it's been so long since we did somebody
for charity as well it feels really
awesome to be back doing that cuz um oh
god I have too many windows up and where
is it no no no no no no all right let's
see if I can
yeah he's he's scribing away we could I
just I'm just putting in notes I'm
checking out the Yogscast thing I'm just
curious what's happening
[Music]
he's watching you tell me to leave no
you should not I'll come back in 20
minutes then it sounds like I totally
miss everything up where is the oh I see
what I did wrong
okay so somebody things happening at
once I'm like what is going on
it's the cry website not working that's
alright you can still donate all the
money will go to crying 74 that's right
everybody I love all the support that
you guys have been giving I think it's
really really cool I'm like genuinely
caught up into playing oblivion over
here excuse me that God is dark now I'm
gonna be live-streaming for another 20
minutes just letting you guys know it's
been genuinely fun to play oblivion as
well just messing around I know I'm
doing it wrong like messing with guards
and all that but it makes it more fun
not crying youtuber cry the charity
[Music]
love from India love right back to you
India all right how far is this
seriously tell me how to all God every
time tell me how to fans travel then and
I'll frickin do it oh it's not how you
do it how do i zoom out okay so that's
where we gotta go
that can't be too far we can do that
oblivion playthrough it's happening here
fast travel press tab for map yeah I did
I did
oh look at it all right here we are in
shading ha oh no my watch will be eating
your stolen goods oh no go pay your fine
oh it's off to the locker I don't think
so I don't think so buddy I don't think
I have a quest to get out Jesus Christ
he actually does a lot of damage
I'm silenced what they can do that
alright so I need to go at the green
spot what is the green spot what is it
is it a door here all right guys where
is it I need to go in here okay oh
that's a Dark Brotherhood in a well is
it down here okay I can't go down there
oh there's the door I couldn't see it I
got it okay okay oh my god it doesn't
move I sort of got the controls for this
is the most annoying shape oh I see so I
have to press that's why okay we're fine
now they can't get in here ah Jesus
Christ that scared me oh please
okay I'm sorry the front door it is in
there I gotta go okay upstairs upstairs
why am I here bread guys please I don't
get all right this is not the end this
is not the end I got a brother it's okay
no just stop there stop notes no-one
gets hard he fought crabs guys yeah this
is oblivion five more fearsome than you
oh they're hitting through many defenses
wait sorry but why am I here again dude
I have so many spells oh I have moon
shadow so I can actually escape okay
that's my plan B right now plan a is to
how do I look at quests again god dammit
I keep forgetting how to play this game
okay okay we're doing it I'm invisible
hahahahahaha [ __ ] [ __ ] you ain't got
me boys you can't see me ah jeez I don't
think that's good what is happening
in the back door the question I'm
looking for is in the back door what
where I'm dying over here guys all right
it's time to die like a hero you either
die a hero
I don't need pants cuz I don't have legs
now let's get hat all right okay
basement there it is
go go go go go they'll never find me
they'll never find me in here torch I
really need a torch geez can you leave
me alone all right what are the spells
do I have now
[Music]
times I can't freaking see anything this
is do something mr. beast oh yes
just open just open just open Green
Green Green Green Green yes yes yes okay
okay this is epic okay this is epic oh
my god dude broke brother groans yes
your new home a place of comfort and
security whenever the need arises I'm
joining t-series guys finally happening
go and speak with Vicente Valtierra
but before you go please accept this
gift from your new family a unique set
of armor lighter than normal leather
okay just give me the stuff all right
cool go dude does that mean I can
actually look at it let me get some
pumpkin and cheese and bread and rat
laughs is good what's the point why
should anyone bother with all that there
we go I'm not even near you fam okay so
this is epic all right is that you that
we're talking to greetings to you our
warmest you've already spoken with
Achieva [ __ ] my design man's for all
new family please do not let my
appearance I have you
likewise Brotherhood come before my own
needs there's a vampire no he's a
vampire to work I can provide you is
that where you guys keep coming eating
about vampires I didn't understand that
all right
a contract is a secret pact one enters
into with the dark brotherhood they
provide us with gold a contract is
fulfilled by a skilled assassin such as
yourself who keeps the dark
Brotherhood's end of the bargain
while carrying out a contract you may
have the opportunity to earn a bonus if
certain parameters are met now let's
begin shall we
okay let's begin yeah excellent here is
what you must do go to the waterfront
this don't joint are you kidding me this
is the Pirates have got a board a ship
go on boy I'm gonna have to go vampire
self on board literally very vampires
were surprised how can I say no today
alright okay I don't care all right this
is it it's at Abed do you want to join
me please join me on bed
all right there's rest for one hour so
now is okay let's sleep for six hours
damn this is epic
we're gonna freaking vampire brows this
is so epic
yeah it just honored yes thank you
harsh son of a [ __ ] don't care whatever
vampire
mom mom a freaking vampire you can't
tell me what to do go to stream are they
done has it been 20 minutes I think it
hasn't yet will they attack me now will
they be waiting oh they won't okay this
is amazing this game is the best
no I can't believe I haven't died yet
literally zero death run
I've not died a single day ever oh god
they're gonna get me in here on thing
that's fine that's fine
oh god he's coming towards me stop right
there okay yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
Jeff yeah yeah yes yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I don't think so I don't think so
I don't think so buddy oh god oh god I
think I might have to I think I might
have to do it boys I might have to do it
oh my god I can't do it I can't do it I
can't do it I can't okay we're going
this way
it's fine it's fine we just need to cry
out who was that who did that
oh he's shooting arrows straight
straight straight straight straight
straight
ow Jesus all right we're good woo oh god
why don't you come huh huh where's my
horse on your horse I news horse any
news
can I fast travel shoot I forgot how
your fast travel you guys told me oh
yeah I hid the map so where did I go
then
where am I going ge says that's far okay
I can't faster on what enemies okay it's
fine
well escape damn my ass looks tight dude
it's okay they will never get me
I'm literally unstoppable now if anyone
has a horse that would be epic
there's a horse
where is he fighting back I think he is
okay Paul right I think he died
no dad
my character look like he thin from a
street yeah you know what a little bit
of joking
okay we got a summon skeleton of course
of course
summon mr. mr. beast go upon do
something they did surgery on a horse
your bank automatically Bain
you thought about Ethan - that's great
see it's not just me Ethan is beautiful
what are you talking about it's got the
same jaw though you can definitely see
that come on
your character has a nice ass I know
okay I think now we can past travel yes
oh that's nice eh you can do that oh
there it is there's a boat this is the
boat from the meems
it's the main boat ah geez leave me
you have nice eyebrows right listen I
just want to board this boat that's all
I want to do all right we just got a
sneaking on the boat
I saw we got out there no one knows
we're in here no one knows we're in the
boat all right we're good
just act cool ah jeez ah jeez ah dude
I've done it now listen listen listen
listen is he killing the guard yeah I'm
not getting tanked
Jesus what happened here what is going
on then 10 did it end and edit intended
I don't go don't don't god dammit god
dammit alright you'll never catch pooter
fine I bet you he won't go out here
ha ha ha ha ha ha that's what I'm
talking about yeah what are you gonna do
shut up
zero-depth everyone come after me
ow choosers what'd I just say
okay it's been 20 minutes now we got a
pop and guess what happens with the
vampire pirate pewter pie we'll just
have to find out in the next live stream
in 300 years now let's check out where
this Jingle Jam is all about twitch
Jingle Jam Jingle Jam I'm being frickin
okay
Jingle Jam jingle Jim what is this
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
is good
[Music]
to just giggly I have no idea what's
happening by the way apparently I'm just
supposed to
[Music]
a little out of out of sync
so what's not keeping the tempo Oh God
good job guys yes I took 20 minutes
awesome
alright alright
okay that word was they let me close
oblivion
now damnit oblivion I don't want to play
anymore we're done that was really fun
playing him lady in there oh what a fun
day what a fun time did you guys have
fun
[Music]
I think it's great we stream for three
hours we had way more people watching
than I thought that's really cool thank
you guys so much for watching this live
stream we hit the goal of 160 well 150
but we hit landed on 166 so that means
in total 176 pounds thousand pounds two
words to cry which is amazing charity if
you still haven't donated you can still
do it either in here on the website
thank you guys a million times for
watching I'm so proud of you guys
we really show today that this fan base
can do something positive something
really cool honestly so proud of you
guys Thanks to everyone for donating
great job I hope you had fun I had a
blast and I think we're just gonna end
it there just kidding there's one more
thing left to do
[Music]
we hit the goal games that's what I'm
talking about can we get some crabs in
the check the nine year olds made a
difference in the world
[Music]
great job
nice moves keep it up rowdy child-labor
it's gone oh thank you guys watching
this live stream I'll see you again next
time
[Music]